when I first reviewed the 2018 iPad pro
I concluded that was not a computer
replacement like Apple's famous what's a
computer ad claimed I mentioned that it
won't replace a laptop until Apple
wanted it to and after spending two
weeks with Apple's brand new iPad OS
which is completely separate from iOS I
can tell you now that you can
legitimately replace your laptop with a
new iPad pro before we get into those
changes let me give you a quick rundown
of what makes the 2018 iPad pro stand
out from the crowd it's the first iPad
ever to pack a rounded display that
makes it look unique and modern it's the
first iPad ever to have no visible form
of authentication touch ID is gone and
there's no notch for face ID so it seems
to unlock magically even while it's
upside-down the new straight edge design
is completely unique made to support
wireless charging on the newly updated
Apple pencil which holds onto the iPad
magnetically for storage and packs a new
DoubleTap feature that greatly boost
productivity the new smart keyboard
folio is perfectly sleek and makes it
feel like you're using a laptop and if
you don't like it there are awesome
alternatives from bridge and Logitech
that work very well it packs for high
quality speakers that make the rest of
the iPad lineup sound like Android
tablets and the display feels buttery
smooth with the pro motion 120 Hertz
technology for the downsides the
headphone jack is now gone but it's not
a big deal since USB see adapters are so
cheap on Amazon it's also expensive
starting at $800 but now that iPad OS is
coming we definitely think it's worth it
over the other iPads especially Amazon
sale price of just $700 and if you're
like me and you want to make sure to
protect your investment you have until
60 days after your purchase or 45 for
smartphones to buy an incredibly
affordable warranty from up see our
sponsor for this video up see works with
nationwide certified repair shops and
helps buyers in the United States save
up to 70% on a warranty compared to
retailers and they make it incredibly
easy to make a claim by having real
people available on the phone 24/7 365
days a year and they store your receipt
and all the info you'll need right in
your UPSI account and you can use the
link in the video description below
with the code max tech today for 10% off
your first warranty purchase so back to
the iPad pro let's discuss all the
awesome new changes coming with iPad OS
that allow you to replace your laptop
first off getting USBC on this I
Pro didn't really mean much since it was
so limited now allowing you to connect
external drives but now we finally have
external store support that works really
well
you can connect anything from a flash
drive to a hard drive or SD card and
transfer various types of files to the
iPads local storage folder you can even
connect multiple drives at once and
transfer files between them you can zip
and unzip files and folders and if you
use split view you can drag and drop
files directly from a hard drive to an
app like bloom effusion and it'll all
work without importing the file to
camera roll or the iPads local storage
we have a full guide on external storage
which you can check out at the end of
this video now there's actually a big
list of iPads that support iPad at West
but the 2018 iPad pro and it's USB C
port is the way to go for external
storage support the old Lightning port
isn't able to supply enough power to be
able to drive various storage drives so
it requires a special camera kit adapter
which plugs into power and even then
some drives still won't work so the
convenience of USB C is well worth it on
the iPad pro one thing that's pretty
amazing is SMB service of port which
works incredibly well allowing you to
connect two hard drives or servers over
a Wi-Fi connection so you can view and
transfer your archived files without
pata Wes you can now open multiple
instances of the same app in split view
like two notes apps or two files apps to
make transferring files easier and it
even works with third party apps that
support it there's also a bunch of new
multitasking features and gestures that
make the iPad much easier to use like
easier ways to select text and finally
an undo gesture that doesn't require you
to shake your iPad Safari has seen some
awesome new updates like automatic
desktop mode that's optimized for touch
and there's a new download manager
similar to what you get on the Mac in
the settings you can easily change the
download location to wherever you want
we were even able to download a
PowerPoint file from Google and edit it
using keno perhaps the best part is that
iPad OS is getting exactly the same
physical keyboard shortcuts that were
already used to on Mac OS both for use
within Safari and basically everywhere
else on the iPad so making the switch is
much easier and if you're using the
on-screen keyboard you'll be able to
pinch it to shrink it down and move it
anywhere you'd like as well as use the
new swipe keyboard which works
incredibly well it's even better for
Apple pencil users
input latency has been reduced from an
industry-leading 20 milliseconds to a
very impressive nine milliseconds
there's also a new tool palette which
can be easily moved around so it doesn't
get in your way and it's much easier to
mark up a page distract from the corner
of the screen using the Apple pencil
from here you can mark it up and share
it or tap the full page button at the
top to be able to scroll through the
entire page and you can even grab the
scroll bar and scroll up and down
without having a swipe and it doesn't
stop there
Apple has finally added bluetooth mouse
support but you don't actually get a
cursor like you do on the Mac you're
basically just moving your finger around
and clicking the mouse to perform a
touch gesture so it's not the best
solution however it does fix a huge
issue with external monitor mirroring
before if you use an external display
you still have to touch the iPad to
navigate but now you can use a bluetooth
mouse and keyboard and set your iPad to
the side not only that but if you have a
Mac running Mac OS Catalina
you can use the iPad as a secondary
display to do things like wirelessly
draw directly into the full Mac OS
Photoshop app using the iPad on top of
that the iPad pro outperforms the rest
of Apple's latest iPad lineup by a
massive margin so you're gonna have no
performance issues and basically any app
or game you try out I previously stated
that people should just buy the 2019
iPad air because the iPad pros
performance was so limited due to
software but I've completely changed my
mind now that iPad OS is coming out
having USBC in this level of performance
guarantees the best possible support for
apps and features for years to come and
it's unique design awesome quad speakers
and the new Apple pencil make it feel
unique and special compared to the other
iPads I'd have to say that paying only
$700 with prime shipping for this iPad
pro or even $900 for the 256 gig model
is well worth the price especially for
trying to replace a much more expensive
laptop I definitely recommend anyone
looking at the 2019 iPad air 2 just save
some more cash and buy the iPad pro
because with iPad OS it's finally become
what Apple has envisioned it to be if
you enjoyed this long-term review make
sure to smash that like button click the
circle above to subscribe and make sure
to check out one of those two videos
right there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]